did section 230 ever come up for you
back in the web logs days
um you know what came up more in those
days was fair use and content
people were kind of stuck on copyright
more than
you know who's responsible as a
publisher and people would say like oh
you
wrote a summary of that story therefore
you're stealing it and i was like
do you understand fair use like if i
comment
on what ma if engadget comments on walt
mossberg's review the wall street
journal was kind of starting to
feel like engadget was stealing it
and then the the wall street journal on
the new york times in reaction to gawker
or
engadget or whichever blog it was
wouldn't link back
and so we got into these holy wars just
about back
and they refused to mention our name and
they refused to link back and i would
as the publisher because peter was
writing it i would ride them so hard
on twitter on facebook on my blog here
are five examples of this journalist
this journalist and this journalist
taking our story and refusing to link to
it here are the five examples of us
linking to them today and then we
started saying you know what we're just
going to stop linking to you
and then that's when because we started
to get more traffic and we were became a
traffic
then people started to give each other
credit but i was the bulldog in that
in that they would send me out to just
attack
every journalist by name you know this
journalist at the new york times refuses
to link to engadget
and here they are and i would just study
them like a hawk here's their five
the last five stories these four
originated from blog posts
and they credited no blogs and people
would be very embarrassed and then i
would email it to
you know martin nieselholz or whoever at
the new york times and he'd like i'm
going to keep calling you guys out you
look really stupid and then they finally
were like oh god enough of this
then there was the era for a while where
like they did actually credit
people but they wouldn't link to them
and that was just stupid it was like
okay
you're acknowledging that they got the
scoop but like here you are trying not
to like
let traffic leave your website and it
feels like we're kind of past that now
if someone's you know reporting on
someone else's scoop they'll they'll
link to
the article but that felt like the like
broken adolescent years
even more insincere than that it wasn't
even about the traffic you know what it
was really about
for them ego in some capacity no it was
even beyond traffic and ego it was about
seo
they literally did not want the seo of
these new blogs
because seo was how you drove traffic
prior to social
so they desperately did not want the new
york times to link to engadget
with the key with the cause they knew
they had domain authority
they had the domain authority over us
and so whether it was the wall street
journal the new york times or any other
new york post daily news whoever they
were under strict orders then we would
watch them and they would put
no follow tags on us so they'd link to
us
and some of them would put no follow
which means you're linking to it but
you're telling the search engines do not
give credit to this and new york times
had like a page rank of 10 and we had a
page rank of two
and so it was always really like a
really gnarly
kind of debate